thank you all for coming I'd like to
introduce our panel aging also has the
privilege of having reading glasses so
our first panelist is going to be you
already know Tom insole director of the
National Institute for mental health our
next panelist is dr. Marlene Berman he's
a Georgia and Helen Dunham Cowan
professor of cognitive neuroscience the
co-director of the Center for the neural
basis of cognition in a professor of
psychology and I should also say a very
close friend and colleague of mine for
many many years our next panelist is one
of our honored guests Theo Arvind Titus
the professor of Health innovation in
health head head of research at the
Institute of digital health care at the
University of Warwick our next panelist
is dr. Allison Baris a professor in
biological sciences and a member of the
Center for neural basis of cognition our
next panelist is another one of our
guests Ming feng li he's the vice
president sun yat-sen university and the
ki aankhon professor of medicine and
Dean planets and Zhang Zhang school of
medicine our last panelist is Tom
Mitchell who is the chief redken
university professor and the head of the
machine learning department so I'd like
to invite the panel's all to come up now
please
have to find your spot
alright you guys already they don't know
entirely what I'm gonna ask them of
course so I'd like to start with
something that leads off of what Tom
Insel just told us about in the brain
initiative and in particular Tom gave us
some of the insight and super did as
well into the potential impact for brain
surf brain research in the coming
decades and beyond what I'd like to hear
from each of you and I would like to go
through all six of you but maybe we'll
lead with Tom Mitchell over on that end
is to share your thoughts on the kinds
of advances technological or otherwise
Tom and emphasize technology but also
other kinds of theoretical advances and
scientific advances that may occur in
the next decade they're going to prove
critical for improving our understanding
of how the brain gives rise intelligent
behavior and then how we treat
dysfunctions of the brain so with that
Tom could you start well let me start
then with an observation the study of
the brain is fundamentally data starved
right we're trying to study something
with your brain has 10 billion neurons
each connected to tens of thousands of
others and a typical life the typical
day in the life of a brain scientist is
maybe to collect data from some
experiment analyze that and try to draw
some conclusions and publish them
there's a key thrust of the new brain
initiative as we heard was to fix that
by collecting more data and obviously
that's one direction we need to go but
the point I want to make is that there's
a second half to the problem of getting
from large data to a theory of how the
brain works and that is the problem of
actually figuring out how we're going to
bring together this very diverse set of
experimental data into a model of the
brain so let me give you a quick example
with my colleague Marcel just over the
last 10 years we've been studying
language processing in the brain so
suppose you're interested in
understanding how the brain makes sense
of language
we've been using fmri and emmy gee brain
imaging to do that and along with other
people worldwide studying this problem
there are already in fact thousands of
different experimental data sets
available that study one or another
aspect of how the rain does language
somebody will run an experiment where
they present just single words to people
and have people read those and record
the brain data somebody else will run an
experiment where they present a story
and have people read that other people
will run an experiment where they
present sometimes words and other times
just nonsense character strings that
aren't really words and they'll look at
the difference between those two so each
of these scientists in a kind of
reductionist way is trying to study one
or another aspect of the phenomena of
language processing and we do have good
news data analysis methods for looking
at those individual experiments and
making sense figuring out for example
what is in fact the difference in the
neural activity if you look at a
nonsense word versus a real word but
what we don't have and this I think is a
key opportunity is data analysis methods
machine learning methods modeling
methods that can simultaneously look at
that very diverse collection of
experimental data the words versus
nonsense words the sentences the words
and foreign languages the stories there
are all reflections of the same
underlying neural circuits and neural
phenomena what we don't have today is
data analysis algorithms that can
simultaneously look at all that that I
think is the key thrust of or one of the
key thrusts that dr. Suresh mentioned in
his talk here at CMU and so I just
highlight that is a huge opportunity and
a huge need so I'll just add before we
go on that certainly is one of the
unique things about CMU that people like
Tom are really becoming neuroscientist
because of the fact that they're
supplying cutting-edge methods such as
machine learning and it's one of the
great things about this place and
certainly in my own work I do human
neuroscience we get frustrated because
you think of this great experiment and
it turns that would take a hundred hours
of someone laying in a scanner to do the
experiment say we can never run that so
we need to figure out ways to actually
leverage all the great work being done
throughout the world so main thing would
you like to add yeah well yeah I excuse
me for my voice after this long travel
from the other side of the earth glad to
be back in town I deeply share a
perspective that the Tongass brought us
about how much and how how badly new
tools are needed to get this entire
field to move forward let me use the
example of a sansa University and
something in China to hopefully to
further that notion a bit you know China
is a big country and the country is in
terms of the brain research and in that
area it's quite unique in terms of the
genetics epigenetics and features of the
population and it is unique in the two
days of industrialization and the
environmental outcome for that and it is
unique in the culture after thousands of
years history and all those factors are
contributing to the brain activities
contributing to the of course behavior
and also neurological diseases and other
diseases but they're not doing that in a
simple way we to study them we need a
lot of new tools and technologies and so
that we can we can put what we're
interested in together for example CSI
University as one of the leading
universities in China and our medical
school
as one of the best medical schools in
China we are seeing while the official
number for our health care system of the
university is that we're seeing we are
having 12,000 war pets we're seeing 12
million outpatient visits a year and
we're doing a 170,000 hospitalized
surgeries annually meaning that we're
cutting at least that number of human
tissues off and we're seeing a lot of
fun neurologic disease of patients and
for example we have a very large theta
and tissue bank for autism oh it's a
four or five digit individuals were
containing that big in our third
defeated hospital which has a big
department for specializing and analysis
autism and but and also on the other
hand a believer not the fastest
supercomputer in the world now
officially tested well it's called the2
is now on the campus of science at
university although we're not the best
computer science school and university
in the country and using that connecting
these two part of things in our are on
our campus has becoming a very
challenging task for all the community
members and and it is always hard for us
to put multidisciplinary experts and
researchers together domestically
particularly in within one institution
that's that's that's a long that's going
to be a long talk about this but anyhow
what we are seeing in discrete in this
brain initiative is a great opportunity
to bring are the people who understand
and can make tools and invent rules are
they can help solve the problems that
we're facing in our medical and other
areas Alison so I was intrigued by Tom's
insoles thought that clarity represents
a revolution in anatomy and I would say
I have really great confidence that in
the next 20 years we will be able to
assemble at least for the vertebrate
brain and that might be for small
vertebrates like fish but it might even
be four mice maybe not quite for humans
that will be able to identify every cell
every cell type in every synapse type I
think we're going to get that data and
so I think what the revolution for me is
actually being able to identify the
different types of cells and the
different pathways and roles of activity
in these different cell types for
different behaviors and different
diseases and you know we're going to get
there but what it does is it puts
biology at the forefront of the
technologies that we can leverage to
collect this data I think we're past the
point where we're going to collect
enormous datasets and then try to
statistically deke involve them into
function I think biology will reveal for
us very specific roles that are very
stereotyped from animal to animal and
we'll be able to leverage what we know
from very simple organisms then to the
human brain yeah yes I liked your
comment about the future especially
looking of the electrical and chemical
circuits of the brain because this is
what we can see coming soon and taking
the idea of the development
hi okay can you hear me now okay can you
hear me okay I'll speak louder all right
okay so talking about chemical and
electrical circuits maybe we can learn
from two cubs we have used already for
so many years through our functional
imaging technologies so for example I'll
bring you what what we do are the
investor worried in collaboration with a
lot of partners at the Midlands area
where we develop what we call in vivo
biochemistry by using magnetic resonance
technology in particular spectroscopic
imaging to understand better metabolic
behavior of disease and we work in
particular with childhood heroes in that
initiative there where we have learned
to pick up interesting biomarkers from
metabolism they tell us something about
discriminating diagnostic cues for a
complex disease like brain tumors and
children but also understanding the
follow-up and the prognosis of this
disease now take this at a different
level if we could transfer this
particular type of information in
understanding the healthy and aging
brain maybe we can have similar kind of
biomarkers that tell us something about
the normal functionality of the brain or
for other diseases like the important
neurodegenerative diseases like dementia
and and the ones that are a burden to
our healthcare system so I think looking
at the biochemistry and developing
further our understanding of metabolism
but further molecular medicine through
imaging technologies will be something
that will be very important in the
future worthy
them I'd like to focus on three main
points that may be able to hold us and
what I take to be the three key
ingredients that are going to be
essential for understanding of brain
structure and function so the first is
the consideration then structure and
function are gradually configured over
the course of learning and experience
and so in order to begin to elucidate
the dynamic changes that take place over
the course of development we're going to
need to design technologies that will
allow us to image the infant brain all
the way through development we there are
some prototype sorry there are some
prototypes on the market we are going to
need special surface coils we're going
to need special head coil special
technology that will allow us to image
the infant brain with high resolution
these will need to be widely distributed
and will begin to aggregate massive
databases that will allow us to examine
how the brains change as babies grow up
and learn over the course of development
there is another technology that I think
is going to be absolutely crucial as
well and that will allow us technologies
that will allow us to image the brain
and a more naturalistic circumstances so
obviously behavior is much more than
what can be measured in the bore of a
three or seven Tesla magnet and so we
need non-invasive mobile technologies
again there are some prototypes around
for tabletop technologies that will
allow us to image the brain under the
full range of complexity of human
behavior there are two other key
ingredients which I'll just touch on
briefly CMU has got a long and revered
tradition in both of these the first is
the interdisciplinary collaboration
we've got to be able to take data all
the way from genomics proteomics through
neural circuit up to complex behaviors
such as algebra and language and in
order to track through that entire
pathway we need to bring together
disciplines such as computer science
molecular individual people who are
working at the molecular level as well
as people who are working on
characterizing complex behaviors seeing
you can and does utilize this kind of
eclectic multidisciplinary approach and
it's going to be absolutely crucial as
we move forward the last point and again
this is a plug for what CM you can do
really well does do well and can do well
is to be at the forefront of theory
building so science is not solely a
bottom-up analytic approach there are
also conceptual and top-down motivations
that determine the nature of the data
that need to be collected cm you can
both theories we have been doing so one
can use computational models to inform
in dynamic real time the kinds of
processes that at least humans undergo
in the service of various behaviors we
can use these kinds of computational
models as scaffolds and skeletons to
improve theory building and the
combination of the tools the cabinet
collaborations and the theories i
believe is what's going to take us into
the next phase of this major initiative
Tom do you want to add some things now
in addition to your talker I have
nothing useful excellent I think the
great ideas of Marina we're getting some
of the granularity that this kind of a
project needs so it's good to hear so
then going to throw down the gauntlet to
you and ask you to answer the first
question so you raise the issue of these
brain mapping efforts for all the way
from mouse up to human and particularly
the human connectome project and the
european human brain mapping project and
there's been as many people in the
audience and I know our panelists are
where a lot of public critiques of some
of these mapping efforts but the
question of how valuable they'll be and
I wanted to hear your thoughts and some
of the panelists lots about how useful
is it to map a system I remember quote
many years ago actually from
evolutionary biology where an ill
understood model with an ill
understood world doesn't really get you
very far and so the question is how will
this be useful and how do we leverage it
into the kinds of theory that Marling's
talking about yeah it's really a
terrific question the one of my
colleagues Eve martyr who's done a lot
of the most elegant mapping of a single
circuit and a simple system has said
that at the moment when she had to go
back to Ellison's point you know mapped
every cell and every synapse and every
connection she still couldn't predict
the behavior of her system that mapping
can only get you so far it may be
necessary it's not sufficient so I I
agree with that on the other hand to
take a really simple system like the
human genome which we spent a lot of
time and energy mapping I think what we
learned from that were two things one
was at the end of the human genome
project we realized that the information
was going to come from from variation
not from the reference sequence that was
published in 2003 that was really
wonderful if you wanted to know how
humans were different from mice are
flies not so helpful if you wanted to
understand what any of these three
billion bases actually did and for that
you needed to look at the three million
points of variation and how they played
out and you had to learn a lot more
about the actual structure so mapping
didn't get you very far on the other
hand that process and that project had
so many spin-offs and again it was a lot
of that was around technology
development and so it was through that
project of mapping that we developed the
sequencing technologies that have I
think really been the basis for almost
all of the major discoveries in biology
over the last five to eight years so
there's something to be said for
embarking on these big mapping projects
even if the reference map you get at the
end is almost the
Roxy it's almost just a way to get to
lots of other things that you can't
predict I should note that was brain
scientist we think of the human genome
project it's a simple project it is
absolutely it's a linear project and we
knew what the endgame was a word you
know we're going after something that is
at least you know who knows two three
orders of magnitude more complicated
thanks Allison did you have some new
understand yeah I would say I agree with
that in general the map is going to
reveal information that's good and solid
information to riff upon to build upon
and without that it's very difficult to
sort of constrain ourselves you may not
know how a horse walks by seeing that it
has four legs but you might be able to
say it doesn't float and I think we need
these constraints so one of the you know
you know having a thrust which we're
really focused on something for example
like the microcircuitry of a very
defined system like a cortical column in
the brain will give you some constraints
to how that may function it's not the
end of the answer but it's the beginning
of the answer Tom to do something you
want to know I just wanted to add that
on if you look at this question from the
perspective if you assume that we would
agree we want to have the schematic and
we want to have a behavioral
characterization what's going on and we
want the mapping between the two in the
end I think that's what we're after if
you think that way then it's interesting
to ask what are the areas where there
has been very significant progress in
the last ten years in terms of
computational models of cognitive
function and I think two areas are where
there really has been quite a bit of
progress is computer vision we now have
very competent computer vision systems
for example in your phone that's why
they find the faces and put a little box
around it CMU company CMU company and
also language processing there is
tremendous amount of resources going
into computer understanding of natural
which in a lot of progress there
fortunately those are two of the key
questions about the brain too and so we
already see work for example Mike
probably is the biggest expert on the
stage in this but we do already see the
beginnings of computational theories of
human visual processing along with
mappings to certain parts of visual
cortex and so looking at the big picture
it's kind of interesting to also take
into account what are the areas where
there is significant progress in
computational models anyone else have
anything like that Marlene but if I
could just build on that just a little
while longer so the idea of adopting
theories and concepts from other domains
such as artificial intelligences one
example is really crucial there are
other kinds of concepts from mathematics
from statistics from physics that we are
beginning to utilize to exploit in the
service of understanding the human brain
mapping a good example in here and I
have already discussed as as things like
graph theory of course decoding and
classification techniques are really
useful to us at this particular point in
time but even more complex ideas from
say percolation theory will really allow
us to leverage in a nonlinear fashion
the data that we acquire from these
high-resolution imaging studies oh my
can i if I can jump in when you in the
first round of questions you ask the
group kind of where they saw things
going in and to go back to Allison's
point I I thought it was really
interesting she started vice as a
biologist by saying you know we still
don't have the basics you know it's it
is great to have the theoretical models
and we'll need that and those can be
important guides but you want to get
that parts list right and without
putting words in your mouth I think what
I heard you say was there are just
really fundamentals like how many
different kinds of cells are there we
know that in model systems like
drosophila or C elegans there's
a tremendous amount of stereotypic
anatomy so you can go into a fly the
same place same cell one after another
and you know exactly what that cells
connected to wear it but it does out in
the case of C elegans ah you know what
304 neurons or whatever every one of
them has a name and identified and those
are animals that are able to do
extraordinarily complicated behaviors
really if you think about what they able
to produce so the rules by which that
happens are really interesting the flip
side of this is in trying to get the
parts list for a human we don't know if
there are human specific neurons do we
have different parts than any other
mammal than any other species and those
are questions that really do beg for an
answer which we should find of pin down
in some way so I think there is the need
for that kind of mapping and just
getting the fundamentals done ooh anyone
else like to anything Theo maybe if I
could Adam not that indeed that the
effort for mapping is kind of a
bottom-up approach from the fundamentals
to understand all the intricacies of the
nervous system and the brain but also we
can learn by looking at top-down
approaches so by looking at existing
diseases and look for example the
effects of connectivity variations let's
say in Alzheimer's or epilepsy by using
surrogate measures that tell us
something about the lictor
electrophysiology or the biochemistry
and through that maybe we can push that
information back to the fundamental to
corroborate the evidence and make it
stronger terrific anything else ok so is
the next question this is an aggregation
of a question was asked by many of the
people in the audience but that's to do
we're going all the way from the lower
level issues of technology up to now
health and there's a lot of interest of
course in the health impact of all this
research and Tom and super both alluded
to that it's a very difficult question
because of course we acknowledge that
there's this incredible challenge facing
the world
cause of the issues related to brain
health and there's a lot of things we
can envision when we can say we can
learn more about the brain and this will
help solve some of these problems but
that this will help solve some of these
problems is kind of a placeholder for we
don't know how to do that yet but we're
going to figure out how to do that and
it's obvious that possibly maybe at the
circuit level or at the molecular level
maybe better more focused drugs but
there may be many cases like traumatic
brain injury or developmental disorders
were there is no pharmaceutical
intervention so I want to hear your
thoughts about how we have brain
scientist and his basic researchers
thinking about translation bring this
into having real global impact it's
affects society directly so Marlene
you're nodding when you like to start
it's a really great question it's
actually rather hard to answer very it's
very provocative and I'll give you one
example just from an endeavor that we've
been involved in recently that may allow
us to make a little bit of progress in
this area there has been a great surge
of enthusiasm both nationally and
internationally to aggregate massive
data sets of brain imaging data from
different diseases so for example we've
just finished analyzing data sets from a
thousand different individuals who of
kids who have autism so this is from 20
different sites internationally have all
archived a data on a on a server and you
can request permission to go and
download these data there are similar
sania Tina's got similar kinds of
massive data the Simons Foundation has
got massive kinds of data especially
genetic data that is a camp that
accompanies the imaging data and this
idea of pooling resources on a global
level i think is going to give us
unprecedented insights into the brain
and will begin to give us a foot in the
door to understand not only the mapping
but also the alterations and the
deviations that one can see at least in
autism and say
deficit disorder in the early stages of
development as Tom pointed out in his
really important slide these are the
kinds of disorders that one sees very
early on but in fact of course have
lifelong impact on the individual on the
family and on society Taman so at the
risk of being a little bit provocative
for those of you who aren't in the
translational realm and who are thinking
about getting into it the important
caveat is don't believe anything you're
told by those who are in it the the
diagnostic system that at least for
psychiatry that people use is is just
fundamentally flawed it's not based on
any science or biology it's based on a
consensus it's a political document not
a scientific one and the therapeutics
which have largely been based on the
development our pharmaceuticals starts
with a black box model of the brain and
assumes that depression means you're a
quart low in serotonin and schizophrenia
means you have a little bit too much
dopamine and it has absolutely no
information about the brain as the way
that our neuro scientists would think
about it so you got to throw all that
out and you'd start from the get-go you
do just as Marlene said you'd start with
let's see where the data takes us you'd
go to someone like Tom and say can you
help us with machine learning to
actually figure out what are the
disorders how many we call this autism
that it's probably ten different
illnesses so what are the right
categories within the autism's that we
should be thinking about the way we
think about cancer today we don't talk
about breast cancer we recognize there
six or eight different kinds that
require different treatments they have a
different biology and the therapeutics
that we should be thinking about is very
different so if these are really not
chemical imbalance problems these are
problems of neural circuits so you can
think of depression as a kind of
arrhythmia if you want and schizophrenia
as a problem around connections and
certainly autism is a connect top
a--they of some sort then your
therapeutics needs to be how do we tuned
circuits how do we use the brains innate
plasticity to actually change the
patterns by which areas connect by which
areas can synergize and that's a really
interesting engineering problem it's a
problem that needs the kind of insights
that people would see him you would have
for other systems and unfortunately that
has not permeated at all translational
space so it does require a completely
new view of the problem and a completely
new approach and actually i think it's a
it's a it's a fixable problem we just
haven't brought the right kinds of tools
to it view so maybe if i could out on
the strain of thoughts that we need to
bring also the mathematicians and
statisticians to help us with pulling
the data i have work in an area which is
a rare disease childhood brain tumors if
we collect data from our hospital is
only a few tens of cases which is
fortunate for the children but you
cannot do proper analysis of anything
you collect so you need to pull data
from across the board so you need to
cooperate internationally we we have a
national network in the UK we cooperate
internationally so for pulling all the
data we need the statisticians to help
us with that meta-analysis of the
information to help us with
standardizing the way we collect and we
store the data and we prepare it for
analysis and as an example one of the
alumni of Carnegie Mellon is were
working at Warwick Tom Nichols and he
has been working in the statistics
department and his effort is to develop
a set of tools for supporting Madonna
meta-analysis functional MRI data for
neuroscience projects and and that tries
to avoid the problems of pulling data
that is incompatible and that creates
biases in the final results I think that
is very important
and I can see immediately were the kind
of initiative brings us together to
solve this kind of problems we have been
trying to do things yeah well I was
going to you are Arab but they're
probably another way of another
dimension of thinking how r this tool
driven approach could help the concept
driven science to to to get some real
breakthroughs like to echo Tom's earlier
point on that in his talk we have pic we
have a lot of say clinical specimens and
we have a lot of clinical information
and large volume of patients and we can
definitely but we sometimes a lot of
times we don't know what to look at and
what kind of data we want to get from
those you can get genetics or genome
sequencing proteomics and maybe a lot of
other things but i think we if we
understand what kind of tools are ahead
of us and what what those tools can lead
us to then we can start thinking better
or more efficiently about what really we
should look at from our are what we have
in the clinic any in biology so this is
how I think it is important speaking of
the Houthis brain initiative and
research can impact on what we're going
to have thank you anyone else awesome
you know it raises this interesting
question about being data starved
because I think that one of the things
that has held neuroscience back is
actually that the it's so difficult to
collect the data that you really are
focused on a very specific hypothesis at
all times and once we break this barrier
of
having enough data it will enable us to
collect and analyze data in an unbiased
way not in this one part of the brain or
for this one cell but across the entire
spectrum of brain function and also
behavior and and I think then one of the
big challenges will be developing
statistical methods and being able to
extract meaningful parts of that data to
link it then back to disease phenotype
or a treatment path and and that's very
difficult right because if you can
analyze every different part of the
brain or every different behavioral
phenotype you can't just do a series of
t-tests to extract meaning you need an
enormous data sample you need many many
individuals and I agree this sort of
collaboration then becomes especially
for human data then will become
necessary Thanks um so I'm going to
follow up with something Tom said he
used the word plasticity it seems to me
that one of the other avenues which was
alluded to a little bit we can think
about a little bit more is taking the
brains inherent plasticity and
intervening in various ways for a whole
range of brain disorders by allowing
basically computational interventions
brain training people heard about things
like luminosity for better for worse
tablet based interventions that can be
used in the home in the school's
cognitive tutors large number of things
video games even and I wanted to hear a
little bit more about your thoughts
about different levels of plasticity in
the brain the brain's ability to
effectively I hate the term heal itself
but at least improve itself either in in
all of us as we age or improve itself in
ways when there's dysfunction in various
ways does anyone want to take that on
well if I were going to if someone asked
me that question directly i would ask
Marlene okay marlena the next grand
panel you can quote that in your gram
you can I
so learning obviously is absolutely cute
too sorry learning is is just key to the
dynamic changes at once season the brain
not just from infancy but you know
through the entire lifespan of an
individual one acquires new information
and that acquisition gives rise to a
particular kind of albeit limited
plasticity of the human brain there are
much more extreme cases of plasticity
kids who've had an entire hemisphere of
the brain removed and they appears to be
some kind of dynamic reorganization if
we could somehow harness our
understanding of what those changes are
and what the mechanisms are they promote
those changes I think we may be able to
capture that we may be able to sort of
use the kernel of that mechanism in
these behavioral intervention techniques
it will be fine to develop tutors and we
ought to go and develop the most
adaptive most cutting-edge techniques
that we can you can have them on your
iPhone you can you can use them all the
time except when you're driving and and
the brain changes in all of those cases
it's not quite satisfying because we
don't actually know what changes when we
really understand the fundamental
mechanism will be able to develop better
tools in the service of intervention I
don't think we should wait but I think
it's going to be absolutely crucial to
truly understand the neurobiology of
learning and memory in order to be able
to optimize intervention and remediation
so this has got to be the last answer
but I want to follow up and that was Tom
Mitchell a little bit so time I know you
have a collaboration now in the whole
department of machine learning with
Yahoo in looking at mobile device
interactions and I think of this is also
a wealth of a data set so not only can
you intervene and have people that
behavior modified through training and
things like this but the kinds of data
you're getting from that is a model of
human behavior at a scale that we've
never had before and we can of course
ramp it up because for all we know Apple
is taking data and all
our behavior all the time certainly we
know Facebook is at this point so do you
have some thoughts about how we can
leverage that kind of thing into really
coming back to addressing a lot of
different kinds of issues that are
facing us in terms of brain health well
it's really a remarkable amount of data
that's accessible through your cell
phone on you know it has many sensors
and there's already interesting research
going on behavioral research to see
whether it's possible to detect someone
who's in depression or not based on
behavioral data from phones and so I
think to connect that opportunity to
this discussion maybe there are two
broadly speaking connections one is
really to get symptoms from this high
volume steady stream of data from the
phone for clinic for clinical conditions
depression and so forth and then use
those to identify and and tamping those
are the people you want to come in and
scan if you're in some kind of project
but the other it is really not a
clinical condition but just learning so
Marlene was mentioning that you could do
luminosity on your phone all the time
but the those kinds of signals from the
system you're practicing on can indicate
that in fact you have learned X or you
have learned why these tutoring systems
know that and so that gives you another
kind of ease and behave well potential
behavioral link back into the education
part of this and that and I think
actually those are two very broad things
that at CMU we should be looking at not
just the clinical thing but also the
educational component which is a very
direct link in with assignment
initiative in other the strategic
initiatives here at CMU terrific let's
thank our panelists again
you